black lives matter co-founder patrice
kohler is lashing out and claiming the
rules should not apply to the group it
comes after the organization's
extravagant purchases like splurging six
million dollars of donor money on a
mansion were exposed
i actually did not know what 990s were
before all of this happened the
accountant handled that like i i don't
know what that is it is such a trip now
to hear the word the the the term 990s
i'm like it's like triggering this
doesn't seem safe for us
this 990 structure this non-profit
system structure this is like deeply
unsafe like this is being literally
weaponized
against us
does anybody want to call lois lerner do
you remember that story when the
conservatives were targeted i don't know
but this is just
how it was just a form
unsafe
and then because it reveals where the
money's going yeah yeah but i mean this
is the you know this is partially our
fault for continuing to overuse the word
weaponized because now it's like just a
form can be weaponized blm used to stand
for black lives matter now it stands for
buy lovely mansions
oh that's really good thank you
here's the problem with that every year
all of us filed tax returns every year
all of us know that we've got to report
income and there are certain there are
certain forms that we have to fill and
then these people she is triggered by
the irs charity rules you know and that
she's unsafe by a form 990 which every
non-profit has to file i mean this is
just absurd i mean i could say i'm
triggered too but nobody listens nobody
cares also are we ever going to find out
why the mansion was 3.2 million and five
days later it was six million dollars
and who was the seller exactly are we
going to find that out
i i
think that this is the the death knell
of blm and i also think that it's
possible people can get indicted
when i was a lawyer for the young lords
here and also some black panthers we had
an expression
you know the uh the war on poverty had
begun
poverty pimps a poverty pimp is a is
someone who went to work for a
not-for-profit or government agency but
really we're enriching themselves right
and i i think that what you're seeing
exposed here is uh is something akin to
poverty pimps they're doing some deep
dives into this they don't have millions
they got billions really and yeah
billions
yeah uh dr wilford riley is doing some
work on this and he can't be over in um
uh kentucky state and he was saying that
this is so out of control and which is
this is a unforced error in that you
have legitimate you have money to pay
the best accounting firm in the country
that would almost do it gratis to be
part of this and you all have to say hey
i don't really know this stuff i got
millions of dollars just make sure i
don't get arrested right they don't even
want to hire anybody and they don't want
to have a board or a ceo to run the
organization here's what's really bad
there are issues in the black community
that need to be addressed that money
could help and instead people are giving
money and they're feeling burned by it
corporations individuals five bucks five
million bucks and they're forever saying
wow i tried to help look at what
happened they bought six mansions and
laughed in our face where is corporate
america that wrote those checks to this
organization's the nba who put it on the
side of the court you should be outraged
because you took your money and they
wasted it and there is a need in the
community for money there's a lot of
corporations
a lot yeah and they don't they don't
really care what you do with their money
they want to virtue signal they want to
i support you but there's evidence by my
mom there's nothing done in the
community for schools or for kids or for
after-school programs all that but
there's a pool and imagine anytime you
ever
lodged any kind of criticism how you
would have been treated when you said if
you say all lives matter you were
considered racist oh yeah you had to
apologize
you were cancelled yeah all right one
more thing is up next hi i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now